une page environnement avec le lancement
prochain en france de certificats
d'économie d'énergie une politique
active qui pourrait déboucher à terme
sur des réductions de la facture edf
quant à l'allemagne après avoir investi
sur l'énergie éolienne
elle s'intéresse à l'énergie solaire une
opération fortement subventionné par
l'état une énergie chère mais propre
correspondance la triste road lkp
l'énergie lumineuse pour la convertir en
électricité
plus de cent mille familles allemandes y
ont déjà pensé à commencer par celles
qui habitent ici sur le toit une
batterie de 36 panneaux solaires avec ça
toute la famille à de l'eau chaude mais
surtout elle peut se vanter de produire
une électricité revendue par le
distributeur local
évidemment il faut s'équiper et ce n'est
pas à la portée de tout le monde
l'investissement se chiffre en milliers
voire en dizaines de milliers d'euros
il faut 20 ans pour l'amortir mais on en
perçoit les effets dès les premières
factures
l'an dernier nous avons consommé pour un
peu plus ses 1000 euros d'électricité
non seulement nous n'avons rien eu à
payer mais en plus nous avons continué à
avoir des 1200 euros les diablerets que
tout le monde soit un jour autosuffisant
car pour l'instant il faut bien
reconnaître que tout cela fonctionne
surtout grâce aux subventions qui
permettent au solaire de prendre ses
quartiers un peu partout jusque sur le
toit de la future gare de berlin
il sera équipé de quelques 800 panneaux
solaires produisant 1 % de l'énergie
consommée par la gare pour son
fonctionnement 1%
c'est peu mais le secteur n'en est qu'à
ses balbutiements si l'on en croit le
lobby du solaire qui revendique déjà la
création de 20000 emplois et s'estime
soutenu par l'opinion publique
keira qu'enfler la guerre en irak a
convaincu les allemands de renforcer
leur indépendance énergétique par
ailleurs les inondations l'an dernier et
cette année la canicule ont renforcé
notre prédisposition pour la protection
de l'environnement
cet engouement pour le solaire révèle
deux obsessions allemande
d'abord réduire les émissions de dioxyde
de carbone comme l'exigent le protocole
de kyoto ensuite remplacer le nucléaire
car l'allemagne a décidé de sortir du
nucléaire elle s'est donnée une
trentaine d'années pour le faire ce qui
lèverait lui laisse le temps de changer
d'avis